und bei mir im studio begrüße ich jetzt
ganz herzlich den politikwissenschaftler
volker kronberg professor kronberg
einige politische beobachter meinen jahr
armin laschet bemerkt gar nicht dass
seine zeit schon längst abgelaufen ist
sehen sie das genauso oder können sie es
nachvollziehen dass er jetzt tut so wie
er sich verhält
man kann das natürlich
nachvollziehen der punkt ist ja also als
abgelaufen weil ich ist immer eine frage
der bewertung natürlich und was dem team
maßstäbe und die gibt es ja nicht
objektiv sondern das sind ja sehr
subjektive wertung 'neben die oftmals
auch interesse geleitet sind denn diese
bewertung jetzt zeit abgelaufen geht er
dann einher damit er ist sehr
verantwortlich für dieses historisch
schlechte wahlergebnis und er war nicht
der richtige spitzenkandidat der punkt
ist der hat das gerade selbst ja gesagt
er ist der amtierende parteivorsitzende
und es ist sicherlich auch mit blick auf
die union das sage ich als beobachter
jetzt zunächst in dieser sehr
schwierigen situation wo man das
historisch schlechteste wahlergebnis
eingefahren hat dass man zunächst
sozusagen das nimmt was da ist er ist
dem amt und er agiert als der
parteivorsitzende natürlich auch als
kanzlerkandidat der ehemann schlechtes
ergebnis zu verantworten hat aber die
frage ist jetzt will man sozusagen jetzt
die chancen wie ist ja ganz objektiv ja
noch gibt stichwort gespräche führen die
grünen sagen wir wollen mit der union
sprechen die fdp sagt wir wollen mit der
union sprechen will man das machen oder
nicht untersagt laschet das will ich tun
und ganz offenbar hat er in präsidium
und vorstand dafür nicht nur eine
mehrheit sondern offenbar eine sehr
große oder gar einstimmige mehrheit
gefunden das zu tun und das sind ja
gerade im präsidium auch die ganz
entscheidenden akteure warum sie das tun
und ob sie insgeheim davon ausgehen dass
er scheitert oder aber nur noch ein paar
tage im amt ist das wird man sehen
übrigens politik funktioniert der
oftmals ganz anders als geplante prozess
darf armin laschet sicherlich auch
spekulieren ich gehe davon aus dass er
auch ein stück weit jetzt auf zeit
spielt sozusagen um zu gucken dass
sozusagen auch die szenerie wieder etwas
in eine milde positiveren licht dasteht
es gibt noch eine chance ihn und er ist
ganz offenbar gewillt die zu nutzen eine
chance für ihn oder für die partei also
was ist worum geht es da
ich nehme wahr seit sonntagabend nach
diesem für das adenauer haus dramatisch
schlechten wahlabend und dem gestrigen
montag dass das im moment zumindest
zusammenfällt er als parteivorsitzender
und die partie übrigens einschließlich
der csu versammelt sich hinter ihm noch
einmal ja das kann kalkuliert sein das
wird sowieso nicht lange halten aber
vorbilder ich nehme auf der anderen
seite auch war bei aller kritik anlass
erstens es in hohem maße anschlussfähig
für die fdp und christian lindner
sicherlich auch für ein robert habeck es
ist ja zweifellos der starke mann der
grüne harbeck und nicht mehr baerbock
habeck hat erfahrung mit jamaika und was
ich auch wahrnehmen es ist drängt sicher
in den reihen der cdu nicht der neue
starke mann oder die neue starke frau
auf und ein machtvakuum an der
parteispitze oder ein langes suchen will
man sicherlich in dieser schwierigen
situation auch nicht insofern stück hat
pragmatisch aber ich nehme wahr noch im
moment stand jetzt laschet und cdu
zusammen bei aller kritik aber es gibt
ja schon erste forderung zur aus den
hinteren reihen der slush zurücktreten
soll kann man diese forderungen
langfristig überhören das ist die
spannende frage ich stehe nicht hier
weil ich es nicht sagen kann das wird so
sein aber wenn ich mir die stimmen
anschaue dann kommen sie ja nicht ganz
überraschend an ein peter altmaier der
selbst ein sehr schlechtes wahlergebnis
zu verantworten hat und bei der frage
welche kanzlerkandidat ja dann auf den
letzten metern noch für söder
argumentiert hat dann die dame aus
rheinland pfalz die ja mit norbert
röttgen im spitzenduo angetreten ist
dass das jetzt sozusagen direkt über
röttgen kommt das sind jetzt nicht ganz
überraschende stimmen die die laschet
ernster nehmen muss glaube ich sind die
der ministerpräsidenten oder der
parteivorsitzenden aus den ostdeutschen
lernen dass man
zum beispiel oder herr hirte das sind
natürlich dramatisch schlechter
wahlergebnisse in ostdeutschland oder
kretschmann ist eine wichtige stimme als
ministerpräsident
von sachsen aber ich nehme eben auch was
sie haben selbst gesagt das ist nicht
der engere führungskreis wir müssen
natürlich auch kritisch fragen wer
gehört denn da überhaupt noch dazu
aber noch ist es nicht soweit dass das
er je in die enge getrieben wird dass
ihm nichts mehr anderes bleibt als
zurückzutreten noch einmal ich glaube
die rationalität vieler akteure die sehr
kritische flasche blicken gehe dahin nee
wir lassen ihn im spiel es drängt sich
jetzt nicht die alternative auch oder
anders niemand anderes kann es im moment
besser machen als er